I think the first thing to realize with
things like the Kindle and other eBook
readers is that they were designed so
that the user had control over the way
things appeared I'm going to help Sean
out here with these little baby camera
so I've got a book open here on meta
algorithmics and one of the things they
want to is when you buy a book on a
Kindle you could display on a Kindle
screen but also on your iPad or on your
mobile phone as well but the difference
between all these is that the screen
sizes are different the problem with
that is that you then have to layout the
text differently otherwise you just end
up with the small text on the Kindle and
lots of white space all around it texts
it can be roughly the same size but you
can use a bigger screen you can get more
on or if perhaps your eyesight's not as
good you can opt to change the font size
to something slightly larger or a
different font and then you get a
different layout now it goes through
that settings day you can't do this with
a book with with a paper book and you
can't do this with a PDF originally when
books are first invented they'll be
putting metal type in exactly the right
place and various stages that they've
been through previously so they could
fine-tune exactly they can fine tune it
they can think let's move them around
slightly so it looks easy it's nicer to
read and the PDF is exactly the same so
this is just a standard academic paper
so the first thing you notice is two
columns but what's actually happening
here is this PDF is just saying inside
put the letter T there at that position
on the page put the letter H there at
that position on the page so if I were
to make the thing bigger the only thing
we can do is zoom in or zoom out the
text is now bigger but it no longer fits
the whole page on though I mean you're
not telling me that every single PDF I
ever read like this one here the person
who wrote it sat there and made all
these decisions I mean surely when this
was written on a word processor or
whether it was first written there were
computers and algorithms involved in
laying this out too like that absolutely
this is probably written in either
something like Microsoft Word or latex
when they were writing it the software
they were using would be making these
decisions so they're making exactly the
same decisions that a typesetter would
have done by hand originally is now
being done on the computer and actually
the Kindles got to make eggs
the same decisions so why can't the
Kindle do what Microsoft Word did when
this PDF was first made what's what's
the Kindle doing wrong
well the Kindles not necessarily doing
anything wrong it's just that they've
had to make slightly different decisions
for a device like the Kindle and they've
had to make for Microsoft Word one of
the advantages that Microsoft Word has
is that when you're typing in the
document and creating it you have to
press the keys and there is a time delay
between you pressing each key so it can
make decisions while you're typing as
you're going so we can sort of hide some
of the calculations whereas when you
turn the Kindle on and open it you want
to display it soon as you turn the page
you want the next page they would have
to wait and see all the text scrolling
across as it lays it out one of the
terms is used when we lay out text we
flow it into a column so we put the test
like water flowing into a thing we flow
the text into the column so when we
relay it out based on difference font
size or different screen size
we're reflowing it to fit a different
size every time I say oh no I'm not
happy with that point size or I want to
change an orientation or I even turn the
page a reflow happens yes
it's having to rework out where every
line ends where every line begins where
everything appears on the page and
because we are impatient people these
days this has to happen needs immediate
absolutely I would have thought in this
day and age with such advanced
technology around us something as simple
as laying out text or reflowing text
would be an instant process anyway this
would be a very easy thing for a device
to do let's turn you into a computer and
let's make you lay out some text and see
how easy it is to do I'm not sure I
would be the recommended computer for
something that
we're going well I think you're probably
about the same sort of level as a Kindle
or something so I've got some tiles and
I'm going to get you to lay out a line
of text on this using these tiles the
line length is between the between the
two sets of holes so I want you to lay
out across here this line has
insufficient length so gently to take
the camera and I'll give thank you and
you want me to start here yeah okay this
time we're definitely in a bit of
time-lapse here Oh see look what you've
done to me I can already see my first
problem arising here in sufficient in
suff what have you done to me all right
the word insufficient isn't going to fit
there so I have a choice here obviously
so what I suggest we do is that we start
off with just a ragged right as it
recalled or left justified okay so next
so I would take the insufficient yep and
I bring it down here in selfish it's I
see is that right yep I believe so
yep hopefully you haven't done it to me
again here you you Kiki
the cut you've done to me yep length
unfortunately also has to move all the
way down to there and I've got a lot of
blank space yeah I think you pre play
into this oh absolutely you and you've
left me with a lot of blank space there
because of the word to chose so you've
been following a set of simple rules
which is what something like the Kindle
will do to a greater or lesser extent it
might be slightly more complicated but
what we've ended up with is probably
about a third of the page is not being
used and we've also ended up with what
would class as a widow on the last line
so what you really want is an algorithm
that keeps everything balanced so it
looks nicely and then it's easier to
read yes
so these things we could do for that so
for example you have the problem if I
move lengths back up here because you
are allowing a tiles worth of space it
didn't fit on so what you could have
done is to reduce the amount of space
slightly if we were using is what's
called a proportionally spaced font
where certain letters are smaller than
others so for example the eye here is
taking four
exactly the same amount of space as the
letter C if we had a small eye you'd be
able to get everything in what we're
using here is essentially a mono space
that's right he hasn't squashed it up
onto the eyebrow suit you mean if we
could do this yeah there we are
so five changing the gaps here what the
computer wanted to get really nice
layout is to be able to make different
decisions and so it could either break
it straight after and leave it with a
big gap or you can say well actually I
can squeeze that up a bit this is an
obvious trick and there anymore
electrics of the trade that can be done
or perhaps one thing that is even
slightly counterintuitive is if we put
this back to where we were before
imagine that there was more checks at
the beginning of here so we can't get
insufficient on here and so we've broken
there but if we broke earlier we could
push insufficient on there and then move
has down and with yeah a line earlier
and if we had some more text beforehand
we've got the word that was
hypothetically before oh yeah has now
flowed in here we've now got a sentence
that looks rather more balanced than we
had before
so what the computer has to do if it's
going to do a really nice layout all the
possible breakpoints you can but you can
say I want to break the line at this
point or at this point or at this point
or at this point or at this point a bit
like a sat-nav deciding which where it's
an exact left and right and it has yeah
and it has to consider all the plus one
so is it going to break line one after
this or after this and if it breaks line
one after this where's it going to break
for line the end of line two is after
there or there or there for that and so
if you do the maps in this case we've
got six words that means is 2 to the 6
possible documents we could make I would
imagine there are a lot of obvious
redundant one exactly get rid of yes it
it still strikes me as something that a
computer if told rules yep should be
able to do really quickly it still seems
II like it was hard for me because I'm
done but it seems to me a computer if
you've programmed and said I never want
one of these I never want you to do that
I always want you to do that the problem
for the computer and particularly for
the writers like the Kindle is that
they're battery-powered and the CPUs on
them are not powerful to keep them cheap
for keeping cheap yeah to make them
affordable and they don't need to be
anymore
so what you can do there are algorithms
and we'll do another video showing
exactly how probably one of the most
famous one by Don Knuth works to break
text that do really nice jobs the
problem is that they have to do lots of
calculations and if you do lots of
calculations you have to expend energy
and the last thing you want when you're
reading a murder mystery novelist of
your battery runs out just as you find
out who Darcy Saito is killed the reason
the Kindle does a kind of lazy layout
and will sometimes leave widows and
sometimes yes these big gaps is because
it's using a very efficient algorithm
exactly yeah won't waste battery so yeah
they decided to take an algorithm that
does a good enough job but trades off
more battery life for really nice
typesetting if they brought out a Kindle
tomorrow with a big fat battery nanyem
and a better CPU in it they could quite
easily make a Kindle that did a much
better job of layer absolutely yes I
mean the algorithms exist
things like later which mathematicians
and computer scientists and sciences
have used for decades the types that
their papers can do really nice jobs
that laying out a document but if you
actually run lay tech then you'll see
actually takes a significant amount of
time even on a normal machine to lay out
the document and you don't want to wait
that every time you turn the page or
change the font size as on your Kindle
you just want to be able to read from
page to page to page
Steve there's one thing we haven't done
yet that I'm sure all the viewers are
going to be screaming at scream
what about doing this putting in a -
where would the - go down the side